hey guys welcome to the Evan and Kalon
podcast the podcast exposing the secrets
you need to know
can we play it's like like x-files music
I think of something like that combine
it if they follow each other wow we
really watched x-files a lot you can
tell that we're experts at the secret
information that you really need to know
experts very nice I was looking through
the Evan and Caitlin podcast community
page and I saw a lot of people noting
that you like when we talk about kind of
the back end of YouTube and oh my gosh I
was preparing today's podcast and I just
like started looking up a little bit of
YouTube news and there's so much going
on and I don't know how I haven't heard
about all of it there's like some big
things that are really exciting so
because we I mean we watch like philip
defranco like we tend to keep up I'm
well at least what Philip DeFranco so
I'm like we know some surface things we
know like we like it's like the ocean
you see like some churning yes under the
water you see like some ruffling yes
above the surface but like I like put on
my goggles
I went underwater and I saw what's down
there what's down there grandpa - scary
things but we'll get to that later first
up this I'll give you some like what's
new things our life our life is slowly
returning to like a more normal place
which is good you know we're streaming a
little bit more yeah some more
semi-regularly and we've even been able
to use our treadmill desk a little bit
we haven't really been able to use it
for like us casually playing games yet
it's kind of like to do is go through
email I was like on Pinterest looking
for inspiration yeah there were some
people who doubted if would like use the
Ted Mills they're like are you gonna use
this I really really want to use this
yeah I mean it's an idea it was one of
those ideas where we were like we're
gonna do this project eventually no
matter what and it happened to pair
nicely with the sponsor but it's one
that we've had on our to-do list for
like yeah months so as we continue
getting our life together we'll let you
know if we actually use it even more and
more so I just wanna like because I mean
I've never been like a fan of working
out man
some people are yeah some people like
really get into it or like one thing
specifically like some people like
really love running you know I really
love swimming I actually would like to
swim more in the future yeah yeah and I
I've never found the thing that I really
love I would just like yeah Treach
through it go through phases stop
working out but my plan because we don't
we don't get a chance to like watch a
lot of shows these days like we'll watch
YouTube occasionally and watch movie
isn't forever and there's like some
shows that I used to watch before we
started the channel that I just kind of
dropped off on so my plan is I want to
start running which is something I've
never really done but my incentive will
be I'll get to like watch stuff on
Netflix that I stopped watching a couple
years ago just to like get caught up on
it
my thing is I want to play real time
strategy games I think that that would
be really great for it well you know go
for walks okay if I work out if I'm
running I'd probably like my activity of
choice would probably be what to watch
those like really kind of like B movies
like they like straight up action ones
that are kind of this mindless like I
kind of want to watch Jumanji or
something like that that's not the new
one oh yeah yeah the new one look like
the rock and everything I heard it's
like a generally funny like thing wait
is it Jumanji yeah yeah yeah we're like
the people are transformed and
at first I thought the og Jumanji no
that's a great movie that's a yeah well
I got like just like I I kind of liked
some of those like fluffy dumb action
movies sound good like a sweet break and
like a good incentive to run no so we
are excited about that yeah if we don't
like if within six months we haven't
said that we've done that you should say
you should publicly shame us hey do that
about us time for the juiciness give me
the juice okay okay so I looked into
this I'm gonna go through this and like
like the order you'd go through in a
meal so I have two appetizers and then I
have the main course tiny little snack I
wonder if anyone has noticed the YouTube
change on the home page thumbnails the
thumbnails have gotten bigger oh I
noticed that but also like the the
quality of the the resolution of the
images have gone up longer titles are
shown but it seems like the community at
large
does not like that well it's it sucks
because you can't see that much yeah you
know like the thumbnails take up so much
space you can't see as many options but
I wonder if that will cut down on
clickbait like long term I'm kind of
like take the devil's advocate approach
here because most people hate it
because a single thumbnail is competing
with less other thumbnails it's less
it's lost competition and also you you
have more visual space to work with
because Kailyn I think we've talked
about this on the podcast before but how
long do we spend working on thumbnails
we have friends that like spend a day or
two days working on the title and
thumbnail and that's like what this
changes it's about as a change in the
title and thumbnail because we've also
struggled fitting like the concept we
want to explain in the small amount of
words that are visible on the desktop
experience you know that's true so it
might change it so it kind of brings it
more in line with the phone yeah you
know on your phone you have about I got
a certain width and a certain title
length and it was longer than on the
desktop yeah
time yeah it's interesting I think you
know I don't know yet
it was I just want the kind of gear
thoughts on it as an appetizer yeah I I
don't really personally like it for the
same reasons that other that I've seen
other people don't like it it cause like
you know comparing it to the phone I
don't like the phone experiences oh yeah
could you have to scroll through so much
you have to scroll through so much and I
can look at a glance on the desktop
version and see the same things that it
takes me a few minutes to scroll through
you know it's really interesting most of
the time we choose thumbnails there no
we choose what video to watch based on
like hey has someone that we like made a
video recently and we can just look at
the home page and see all the videos and
choose the one that you like I know most
people go to their subscriptions for
that but we've never use our
subscription I know it's weird every
time we go in there we unsubscribe
our subscriptions feed this kind of
useless yeah it's weird yeah yeah we go
to the home page we see like Oh any of
the channels we normally watch here no
no mom I guess we'll find something else
no go to Netflix or something yeah it's
interesting yeah yeah I don't know it
will be interesting to see if it changes
thumbnail and you know strategy and
we're gonna have to like we like one
thing that Caitlyn and I do when we're
designing a thumbnail for our videos is
we have a Photoshop mock-up that we do
and we Photoshop our thumbnail into a
batch of typical thumbnails and we see
like on like a mock-up of what you'd see
Lucy doesn't stand out is it I catch in
is it does it like visually vibe with
we're gonna change
I know anyways okay so that's an
appetizer this is this is like a
slightly bigger appetizer how many
courses is meal three this is the second
of three there's no dessert no the thing
of the week
dessert is a thing of the week yeah the
positive delicious cherry on top
okay of this stew
this kind of likes to eat all of this
none of this is really good
that's going on with YouTube I may be a
mixed bag but YouTube kids we talked
about this a little bit ago yes and
there's this updates Caitlyn do you know
that now that YouTube is like nope not
us um everyone who has YouTube channels
has been getting notifications now
saying like alright you need to mark all
of your videos are they for kids or are
they not okay yeah okay so before this
big change in the kids content they're
kind of to YouTube's there is YouTube
and there's YouTube kids YouTube kids is
where everyone under the age of 13 was
supposed to go and of course that didn't
happen at all I mean young kids watched
YouTube and within YouTube there was
some age gating to content mainly it's
18 plus content YouTube's identified it
and kind of hid it
so within YouTube there was like some
hiding a little bit but it's all within
the one app now the government is the
FTC sued YouTube for collecting data on
kids and people under 13 because kids
were watching content on their like
parents accounts yeah not in YouTube
kids and based on this law called Copp a
Coppa that's illegal and YouTube was
doing it and so they got fined so now
what YouTube is doing is saying like hey
we can't regulate it
there's too much content uploaded and we
don't want to shut down YouTube so we're
passing on all responsibility to
creators so now when we upload a video
we need to choose this is not for kids
yeah it's and and they're like there was
an old upload the future and then
there's a new upload feature and the new
upload feature you need to check it and
when you use the old one that says hey
warning you're not checking the thin you
need to go check the thing it's like a
big thing but we did the whole thing for
the whole channel yes now a default - no
last video no no yeah yeah
but anyways if if if we if a channel
breaks that rule Kaitlyn the law has
stated that they can find us up to forty
two thousand five hundred and thirty
dollars per video per video so it's like
if you're a channel and you have a
hundred videos and the FEC go see your
channel says hey those 100 videos those
appeal to kids they could find you like
four million dollars that's insane it's
insane
well that's it's hard because like okay
yeah the early kids some stuff clearly
not directed at kids like child
appealing like topics or characters and
stuff like that like like I like our our
our niece um she really likes this one
wish character and she could she be
grant matric wishes and I think that if
we did a video based all around that
that's obviously kid appealing because
it's around a kid show and it's very kid
but like what about Minecraft okay well
here's here's one thing I'm wondering
okay so we have he's a patron and his
channel he has like a character he plays
it's that monster maker oh yeah so it's
like a maker Channel but he has a
character he plays that like very much
comes off like it's like you know from a
kids show yeah Wow
you know and he has like this crazy set
it's all colorful and he's like doing
like woodworking and making and this and
that so he's doing projects that a kid
probably wouldn't do but his his
character like is very kid not just kid
friendly but it almost feels like kid
direct in yeah so I wonder I don't know
I feel like there's a lot of there's
probably tons of examples you're just
gonna have to start cursing and all this
I know there's some stuff like like mine
I mean minecraft that's a great example
though but I mean like and the reason
why people don't just say oh okay
I do make kid appealing content but
there's huge downsides to that you'll
probably cut your revenue by 80% loss so
you'll only be making like 15% of what
you were making you won't be able to
like you won't be able to comment you
won't be able to do all these things all
these features that make well done that
you want that people won't be able to
comment on your video oh yeah yeah your
videos and you you won't people won't be
able to like your videos they won't be
able to your videos might not autoplay
there's a lot of like no downsides yeah
so I mean there's a big incentive for
people to not report yeah but I'm sure
there's a lot of channels that kind of
walk that line yes I know there's like
well there's a lot of channels that are
like completely kids content totally but
but also think about like so so there's
a family vlog I think I heard about on
philip defranco oh well yeah yeah if
there's a kid in the video it's very
strongly like if you if you're like
content features a kid
that like makes off with their kids yeah
that might be kids directed and then you
might need to check that box which means
that video is gonna go crash burn
interesting cuz like if you're no no
this isn't fully set in stone YouTube is
putting all of these things in place
people are fighting that craters are
fighting it we're gonna be linking down
below to a change.org petition so that
same one it's almost up 2/3 300,000
signatures and you can also reach out to
the FCC directly about this rule and
we'll put that link down in the
description
yeah fast easy okay FCC yeah yeah
anyways it's just like such a huge thing
because like it's like by publishing a
YouTube video you are opening yourself
up to a lawsuit by the FTC and there's a
video of this guy at the FTC and he
basically said like
and going after these YouTube videos
going after these content creators
they're like fish in a barrel
those are the words that he used for
people that he thinks are violating the
Koopa ruling he says content creators
are fish in a barrel and we're gonna go
after them and I'm like I wonder what
will happen to think about what the
current content is like but think about
something like like a Jake Paul type
channel where like there's clearly lots
of stuff that's not appropriate for kids
but he's also clearly trying to get that
kid attention yeah you know what I mean
like by having kids on by doing like
challenges that appeal to kids by like
saying things like tell your mom / merge
all these changes go into effect in 2020
so I think that like pretty soon
I don't know YouTube the landscape of
YouTube might change a lot I know a lot
of you guys watch YouTube but I thought
that like if you hear people talking
about this or you see changes being made
it might be because of this if your
favorite kid friendly content pay
$42,000 fines you'll probably just throw
one one f-bomb in there like crazy yeah
just drop it gosh darn it and the poop
every now and then I honestly think that
all of our main videos should be
completely fine I think they should be
fine because I actually do worry a
little bit about a gaming channel I do
worry about the Minecraft yeah yeah
yeah well yeah and other games it's like
like guys we just found minecraft we
love minecraft just let us play this
[Laughter]
content we just need to make more and
more innuendos yeah just toe the line
yeah just toe the line yeah you know not
enough to be considered at 18 plus
restricted no but enough that clearly
our jokes are not meant for kids yeah
all right
that's what she said that doesn't make
sense I'm just like I just feel the need
to say it that's what she said that's
what she said
totally remind me of Michael force I
mean that bad she said Michael Scott
yeah yeah that's my point
ya know it's like like the way you said
it it was like so perfectly like Michael
alright the meat the meat the secret
sauce that's your store give me that
beef stew alright so um content craters
they're like you know there's this this
group of people who like a little bit
ago we're just like investigating all of
the HTML all of the CSS all of the
backend of YouTube videos and guess what
they found Kaitlyn a Peace Corps Pete a
Peace Corps yeah and what that stands
for is like popularity passion
protection platform production it's like
an internal ball get that later I'll get
to that later
basically it is YouTube's ranking of how
good your video is for advertisers like
it's a number Kaitlyn it is a number ah
wait so what are the peas again so I'll
get to that a little bit but basically
oh my gosh this is something that like
Cu has been speculated about it has been
talked about some about what determines
people's CPMs it's partially what
determines their CPMs and if you get a
high enough Peace Corps you can be part
of the YouTube preferred program which
means you're like you and so much more
from YouTube videos if your YouTube
preferred basically that means like if
you're a really big you know company and
you want really safe channels you can
say hey I'll to pay extra for youtube
preferred these are the safe channels
you know changing now I don't know do
the kids stuff well if you if you look
at it let me pull it up right now
let me know if you see a trend here just
read out some of the top names top names
yes this is the highest this is the
highest Peace Corps okay and in order
from top to bottom high right go for the
Late Show with Stephen Colbert Late
Night with Seth Meyers
The Tonight Show was time Jimmy Fallon
The Daily Show with Trevor Noah Jimmy
Kimmel Live CBC News Fox News - active
it's like you know he's very he is kind
of a safe because it's honest about
computers and stuff Will Smith is up
there there are some but also
five-minute crafts is up there yeah I'm
gonna go into what the Peace Corps means
also in a little bit okay crafts will
get next okay so this is what determines
your Peace Corps popularity repeat
engaged viewership okay Helen there you
know people go back again and again
again popularity that just means like
popular news this kind of [ __ ] how many
views and how many of them are returned
views so if you guys watch a lot of our
videos and come back a lot that's really
helping our popularity score it's almost
sounds more like a loyalty score but
it's also just like the reviews yeah
yeah so it's like the more views the
better your Peace Corps is for
popularity but repeat engaged yes that's
especially good passion how engaged they
are just like we said in the you are the
algorithm just like we speculated
comments shares likes raise your Peace
Corps because that shows how engaged
your audiences yeah so protection
content suitability said does kind of
tie in like that's like they scan your
content is there anything mature is
there anything not safe is there
anything that like my age gate you or
whatever so that's that that's one part
of it platform this is so interesting
you get extra points if people watch
your content on bigger screens
and that kind of makes sense it does
come people are watching on your phone
also if you're watching on a phone
you're kind of on the go your your
screen might be locked you might have it
to the side you might have it like down
and away or something like that ention
if you're on a computer you might be
paying more attention but that the gold
in the cream of the crop is if you play
our content on a TV that means it's
entertainment
that means it's like watching a show
yeah so it's like watching our content
on TV raises a peace corps that's so
that does like blows my mind a little
bit interesting characteristic because
it doesn't make sense yeah like you're
more likely to have a like more slightly
more captive audience yeah and you're
sitting down you're like watching it
you're not like you're not as distracted
yes if you if you have a high platform
Peace Corps that means that like like
people are watching your content from a
couch basically I know and then this
kind of goes online to production
sophisticated camera work and cinema
graphic technique that raises your score
are they measuring that I don't know is
it like is it like if it's just probably
like a static like this video right now
probably there's a really low production
score is just a few of us sitting here
like dungus --is like just with a static
background like full noobs we're using
the add some camera shake
add some pans add some explosions in the
background are you saying that yeah so
okay so an algorithm I feel like it's
theoretically determined that like if
it's one camera quality like you're
you're doing like are you uploading at
1080p are you at like Oh super low well
I also think that like like well like it
can take image it can take still images
of your video run it through an
algorithm and see how good your camera
is basically are the lines crisp is
there contrast is there
there's no depth of field it can like oh
you Google can totally like grab a still
image from your video and judge it
completely they could totally do that
that's interesting that that would be a
factor the crazy thing is after these
content creators came out this list
published this thing got this press all
like the you can't find the P scores
anymore they're not they're hidden yeah
I know yeah we can't find ours so these
this team of content creators they went
through the internet and they found like
they just looked at 234 channels and all
standing next to Caitlin and I was
googling some of these like channels
with low P scores and Kalin looked over
once and I was like oh kids like it was
like I was like a weird there's a weird
channel with weird thumbnails that
weren't fully appropriate weird just
like looking at these weird channels and
stuff my research over here but I could
kind of tell III see what they're
talking about with this Peace Corps but
what's crazy I mean you know one channel
that we really like nerd City left a
comment on one of these videos saying we
need to have this Peace Corps and all of
its component ratings visible to the
creators it's unfair to hide this and he
was kind of saying like look why can't
we see what our Peace Corps is and I
understand the counter-argument of well
if you know your Peace Corps you you can
hack the system you can try to but then
like when you reverse engineer it and
like like playing devil's advocate to
that statement if that resulted in more
channels being more advertiser friendly
wouldn't YouTube like that yeah I kind
of agree with that actually that's a
really good counter counterpoint it's
maybe not the best in terms of like
diversity of content on YouTube because
if you people will all be like strict
you know anyone who's trying to like do
it as a job will be striving for these
like Peace Corps norms yeah you know but
if you're YouTube you could see
as like well hey if we publish these P
scores and everyone's trying to like up
there camera work get their audience
more engaged by asking them to comment
like yeah all these things that make
them better for advertisers wouldn't you
- Blanca no it's really interesting is
Google put out this this Peace Corps a
little bit ago back in April of 2019 but
it got very few views because this is
like this is like an unlisted video I
think it's on YouTube advertisers and
it's targeted towards advertisers like
like hey advertisers are you wondering
like how we like ensure quality and
stuff we have this Peace Corps like it's
made up of all these factors so you know
that like when you spend money here it's
going towards good high quality videos
that you can trust and then it was found
that that report came out two weeks ago
I'm sure um Katelyn the comments so this
came out April 10th a while ago and all
of the comments all these angry people
all comment in two weeks ago when this
all blew up and the like to dislike
ratio is like it's real rough this this
kind of upset people but at the same
time I mean this is like a big thing I
think this is a huge revelation
revelation yeah and it only has like
fourteen thousand views I don't know
that's crazy it's crazy man it's a lot
to process
it's a lot to process and YouTube
creator insider put out a video kind of
responding to it clarifying some things
addressing those issues I think that's
really cool I like that Tom got out
there he's one of the engineers there
and he tries to clarify things like from
the engineers behind the scenes and like
what all of this means and stuff and
that like clarifying video only has
7,000 views so this whole thing it's
like it's like 7,000 views and it's such
a big thing it's like such a I think
it's huge I think it's huge - I mean I
remember back when the like D
monetization scores yeah where well I
like first found
I think nerd city was the first one yeah
we saw it yes such a big thing it's it
just seems like it would be just as big
of a thing the people looking at all
that so the people looking at all the
the people who looked at the code also
found so they found the P scores they
found a rating and a throttling status a
throttling status so like if that video
is throttled for one reason or another
like that was some part of that date it
was like publically available to and
we'll link to like the article riding up
all this more in detail but it's like so
crazy but the creator insider updates on
this I think it's really interesting
they said they kind of stated in much
more words stuff that we've been
guessing at for a while and they said
look the monetization team which to have
the Peace Corps is separate it's a
separate team from search and discovery
you know so he said there's separate
teams different goals different
objectives but he did say that like you
know both one ization and search and
discovery may use similar data and
potentially overlapping data like one
example he gave is mature content what
the monetization team might not place a
sponsor who was afraid of that
on that video if it's been flagged for
mature content on the search and
discovery side that if the viewer that
is watching the videos is more of a
general audience viewer and hasn't shown
a preference for mature content that
video will not likely be recommended or
play next if it's been flagged for
mature content so that's like one data
point that's affecting both in similar
ways but like independently in air
quotes but like look your Peace Corps is
probably and like a slight indicator of
what your search and discovery score is
like but even if it's not even if it's
not yeah even though even if the piece
course only determining how much money
you make on ads only your livelihood
yeah yeah which in some ways I mean the
two are tied like views and how much you
make per view yeah
if they're both important because they
determine like alright can you make a
living doing this or not yeah but also
like you know old YouTube at some point
in the past was just based around views
you know if you got views you you did
good you know and I think that's how a
lot of viral videos happened yeah you
know like there's this one video that
just like boggles my mind I want to pull
this up because this this is like the
video that sticks in my head for like
why did this video eleven point nine
million views it's a it's a channel
that's not very active their average
channel like video views are between
like 50 and 200 maybe and this video
that I'm referring to is just like a
nest recording of a driveway and this
refinisher comes to seal it and it's
just like the algorithm like freaking
out and it just like it just doesn't
make any sense but this is kind of like
what might have happened in the past
like somehow this video got clicked on I
got clicked on again and because I got
more views it got more clicks and it's
like but why does this driveway video
have 11 million views and then I clicked
it I one of those mm people couldn't I
well why is this showing up and my
recommended with 11 million views about
a driveway it must be great it's not
it's not good at all and I think that
like this might be killing viral videos
like this but even just like viral
videos in general like Star Wars kid you
know like the old school old viral
videos like I wonder what effect all
this will have on that because there's a
definite definite preference to like
entertainment content you know like
content that competes with like the
Netflix and the HBO's and more like
regular like regular shows yeah we're
not regular necessarily as in it's like
a TV show but like it's put out
regularly it's consistent yeah it's a
certain level of quality although I kind
of feel like the
old style of viral videos like has been
dead for a little bit yeah just I mean
it can still happen every now and then
but I feel like it's so it just seems
more rare I mean maybe I'm just enough
in a YouTube bubble now I don't use it
the same way as I used to back in you
know college yeah but like um and the
when I when I found out about the P
score I just knew we had to do like an
entire episode on this because like once
this gets out more broadly I wonder if
that's gonna affect content in general
like I didn't know that production yeah
like like boggles my mind I wonder I I
really wanna know what's our production
score good job what's our production
store on our main videos verse our
gaming videos cuz our gaming videos have
a lot of editing done or editors do an
amazing job with like zooms and changes
and all sorts of stuff but I wonder if
it recognize this that it's a video game
do all video game contents have a lower
peace core but at the same time a lot of
you know channels with high P scores
where a gaming content you know it's
like there are people really high up
there like jacksepticeye PewDiePie
vanossgaming but also one thing that's
interesting first we feast which has hot
ones is really high up there with the
Peace Corps but cold ones which is about
drinking beer and answering questions
that has a really low Peace Corps yeah
maybe because it's about drinking this
beer I don't know but it's a similar
format but like first we feast really
good Peace Corps cold ones low Peace
Corps that's so interesting any other
like I haven't looked through this
enough
Jake Paul has a high Peace Corps yeah I
think that's cuz like because it's like
such an odd mix of things you know like
if you have a good enough viewership
that can just raise your Peace Corps by
itself because there's things on here
that I wouldn't think of because like
they've kind of been deemed as not safe
not safe yeah
like like Jake Paul yeah for example
like I would think that wouldn't that he
would be deemed not as safe for three
podcast I know a podcast I said that his
his Adsense isn't that high but at the
same time like this is the aggregate
Peace Corps I wonder if like one Peace
Corps is more important than on the
other like what if like you know in
order to pass a certain threshold your
protection Peace Corps needs to be high
enough and maybe like you know the
podcast has a really high popularity
Peace Corps but a low protection Peace
Corps I don't know you know it's like at
this point we're just like guessing and
theorizing again because no data because
it's private but it's it's it's really
interesting it's not interesting there's
there's so many it seems like more and
more regularly there's stuff like this
coming out or like YouTube secret codes
YouTube secret scores YouTube secret
numbers and like YouTube's a big company
but YouTube's also got a large amount of
users and I feel like people are just
gonna keep cracking this stuff but at
the same time I mean I think that like
they will continue to hide that data and
at the same time look algorithms control
everything because that's the only way
that's that's the only way like like
they try to hide the Peace Corps
someone's gonna find out how to find it
again oh you think the view are gonna be
able to find the Peace Corps again so
because it's just you know at YouTube
there's people like right helping to
write the BOTS or do the things that
make the decisions but there's a lot of
people who also want to find those
things out who have found out a lot of
stuff already but maybe like the Peace
Corps will just be hidden and it won't
be visible anywhere even internally at
Google you know I don't know I don't has
to be visible somewhere how they say
advertisers
I don't know yeah I guess some people at
YouTube must have access to this the
Peace Corps crime I think um there's
gonna be
eh-eh anonymous group of YouTube
recently things gonna be reform no no
that form a company and pay to advertise
on YouTube just to get the backend info
and then they see what channels show up
based on what criteria and everything
and then any of that they can like cuz
if you know you know you don't need to
know what the black box is if you feed
stuff in and you look at what comes out
the other end you know you understand
what the limits are what the that's
really interesting
yeah and if you pay more like like
increase your budget higher and then
lower and then see what channels show up
and disappear mm-hmm like say you're I'm
sure the advertisers have some ability
just that their criteria you know yeah
like maybe everything is important to
them except the content suitability
maybe they're like put us on on any one
we just want it the popularity score to
be high yeah you know yeah we just want
a balls just eyeballs like it seems like
it would be logical that they would have
some say in prioritizing those things
yeah well one thing that's interesting
quick question knowing all of this would
you have changed anything that we've
done yeah I don't tell you there
I think it's more fascinating the only
thing that would change is starting our
channel earlier because all the people
the time are either like TV slash
traditional media people or they just
started a really long time it started a
really long time that's the only thing
but I wouldn't change how we've done
anything but you know it's another
interesting filter like I've been
thinking about the Oh to start a long
time ago and to stick it out and you'll
you'll be a lot higher and to some
degree that's true but at the same time
like between the people who started a
long time ago like back when Shane you
know started and everything if you think
about how many people started YouTube
channels between when he started and now
and then like between three years ago
and now it's like so many people like
create channels and drop out drop out
drop out drop out drop out so it's like
yes if you started a long time ago like
the people who are still around and
started so long ago they're all big but
also it's just like partially the
because they survived because they
succeeded you know we are only seeing
the people who did well and we're not
seeing all the people who started seven
years ago that like I make the
assumption that like if we started then
we would still be around yeah
like but at the same time one thing
that's so interesting is back then back
in the earlier days of YouTube the
content that we're making it might not
have done well people weren't sitting
down like like if we made our video now
it's like can you see it like getting
shared and going viral and like the old
ways cuz like no 23 minutes yeah
back when like Shane started like that
wasn't what people made they made like
really quick funny skits and sketches
and stuff quick funny skits and sketches
you have a would we have wanted to build
up our channel around that it's a lot of
rapper to be funny
yeah that's a good point I mean you know
like going a little bit behind the
scenes I mean we I think we talked about
Morin in the coming after show or well
an after show we're gonna record
tomorrow probably but the intro to our
next video we struggled a lot with that
intro because we're trying to make it
funny we're trying to do a skit and like
we struggled for day and a half yeah I
think another interesting thing about
like was going back a bit but a
potential downside to starting earlier
is you know we a lot of people start
YouTube just as like a hobby we started
it hoping it would become a job because
we wanted to work together it seems like
a fun way to work together but if we
started it you know ten years ago it
wasn't something people could do as a
job as a job not nearly as easily you
know um and so maybe we just wouldn't
have started it I don't think we don't
know I think that like
like for me maybe but for you I think
would have been really hard because you
are very practical yeah and you wouldn't
back then you wouldn't have known that
like it would be worth it in five years
yeah it was much more like play it safe
my internship and I got the job at the
place I had the internship at and you
know you started the internship before
you'd even graduated oh yeah of course
yeah yeah that's interesting anything
different I don't think I would have
done anything differently but like you
know the reason why I'm saying that is
because we do have a success a
successful channel I mean it's like
partially because we did succeed that
we're like well I wouldn't have changed
anything because we've succeeded you
know that's true but it would be
interesting if we had let's say um you
know in all of our videos we had our
niece with us oh my gosh cuz it's like
oh that would be so cute it'd be like a
fun stick and our niece is super cute
and when it'd be fun if we did projects
with her oh you know if we had gone down
some kind of path like that where we'd
be more at risk for being considered
child-directed or even if we made a
video like where we made something for
her and she was like a central character
to the video then then maybe that one
video I'm thinking more Channel why but
even then that one video might be marked
as the we would have to say like yes
this is intended for kids and then we
can't do that channel wide say different
things if we were I mean this is two
different things they're looking at the
Peace Corps and then like the child
directed content that yeah and then the
the child directed content isn't like
set in stone yet but it's looking like
it's going in that direction you know
one of the most interesting things about
the Peace Corps that like gets me is
production I know right because like one
of the big messages of YouTube is like
you know anyone can do it anyone can
start filming themselves and uploading
and yes that's technically true because
like you know phones have such good
cameras these days and this and that but
it still seems kind of like anti YouTube
yeah
because part of the like if I if I see a
video that's too polished and seems like
it's a company doing it I'm kind of
turned off by it and like but at the
same time I mean popularity kind of
counterbalances that seems like
popularity might be one of the most
important thing is based on that Peace
Corps list that were like yeah like like
the late-night show with Stephen Colbert
has like the highest Peace Corps and it
has really good production value but
like honestly PewDiePie is a lot more
popular okay so looking at the chart
yeah I'm looking at some of the top P
scores hmm but some of them have
relatively low subscribers like CBC News
has 1.5 million oh yeah these are
probably very small compared to everyone
else but they're probably the safest of
everything up there they're safer than
the late-night show or Jimmy Kimmel
because they might like use edgy humor
or something like that
if CBC News got a really like pristine
like the safest score ever then then
that might boost them you know it's like
again we can't see how this Peace Corps
is broken down a decent amount of money
to like have full access no no I'm not
gonna not that I'm driving but like I
was I really I'd really enjoy like a few
hours just being able to browse the full
Peace Corps of like any channel like
this out of sheer curiosity I don't
think I've change anything but I'm just
like so curious I just want to see yeah
it's very fascinating to look at this
list again we're gonna link the list
below so that you can like we were like
waxing poetic about this list you can
look at it with us yeah it's just so
fascinating
and some are just like talking head type
things and then yeah production yeah cuz
like the game the game theorist is just
like well actually the games they have a
lot of special effects and stuff like
the game theorist is just voice over and
a whole bunch of graphics yeah and stuff
yeah and the odd ones out that's like
all like hand and made and stuff like
that actually has a really high
production value because he entirely
himself yeah we're with the team I'm not
fully sure ok so here's an interesting
one number 67 on the on this list of the
top like 230 is philip defranco but it's
interesting because he's always talking
about how all the time so why is he
getting to monetize all the time if he's
in the this top like 200 list but it's
not a top 200 list so it's 200 random
ones and they're rare so philip defranco
being 60 was it 67 he is almost like
like you know the people made this less
they just kind of went around random
just got like a few you know some of the
bigger ones and just some people they're
curious about but they they just it was
just a random thing um so philip
defranco being 67 isn't necessarily that
great gotcha
these are just like people ranked in
order so funny YouTube's own channel is
like yeah probably cuz it gets really
low likes it gets really low popularity
and stuff youtubers videos don't do that
great very interesting yeah I feel like
this is gonna blow up soon you think so
I think though cuz I don't know I think
it will be maybe a slight delayed effect
cuz like like you like the whole boat
when I say blow up I mean blow up
internally amongst YouTube in order for
that to be covered like it'd have to be
like
Philip DeFranco talking about and Jenna
and Julian and you know like PewDiePie
and that's like it's like all these big
talking happy or not talking happy but
like you know the the big like big
people of YouTube because the light
isn't going to be shined on to this by
like CNN I'm saying it's gonna be like
Philip DeFranco and PewDiePie hmm you
heard it here first though I don't know
where I came from all right well I think
that that kind of concludes the the
Peace Corps I don't like harp on it too
much but like I'm just I'm just like you
know we're probably going to walk on our
treadmills later and keep on chatting
about this yeah all right but for now
let's move on to thing of the week
my thing of the week is blue tape and
you might be thinking duh Evan loves
blue tape and blue tape is amazing but
this is not just any blue thing this is
exterior-grade blue tape yes we first
found that when we were working on our
door exterior yeah because we wanted to
leave like drop cloths taped to at the
side of our house for days because we're
painting the door open
yeah and and so we got this and it
worked great for that and we've just
been finding ourselves using it again
and again and again and again it's like
blue tape it removes really easily but
it's stronger better it's like it's
great in all ways it's like blue tape on
steroids yeah it releases with this like
without residue yeah it's like it's like
it looks like an under known under I ran
out of words it's a little-known thing
that's amazing yeah
and that's why it's my thing of the week
because I just feel strongly about that
we've been yeah we I think are almost
out of our roll yeah we did more okay my
things kind of random so yeah not too
many nights ago I was having a hard time
sleeping and I was like I just need to
pull up something brainless because my
brain kept going down all these idea
rabbit holes and this and that and so I
open read it and I saw this video where
it was like it looked like a why am i
blinking on the words the underwater
robots oh not from Ray
no no that they're like not manned
ROV bogeys yeah remote operated vehicle
that's why I had Rover in my head yeah
so it's like a ship on the surface
dropped this robot down underwater yeah
so it was a video where this robot had
come across a whale fall I think was
cool yeah
like a whale dives falls to the ocean
floor and creates this ecosystem of all
these other animals yes and by the way
the preface this Kaitlyn loves deep sea
love like especially like creepy ish so
I'm so I clicked on this video and the
thing that I didn't expect is that you
know I'm like watching from this robots
point of view but there's all this
commentary and it's all these marine
biologists who are like oh is that a
whatever whatever shrimp oh my gosh is
it whatever whatever shrimp it was very
awesome
it was so wholesome and they're getting
so excited about this whale father like
an octopus oh my god and they're just
freaking out in the most wholesome way
about this this whale fall and I'm like
okay I need to know like what's going on
here so I click on the channel and they
it's called um Evie Nautilus and I went
to some of the top videos and they're
all like two to five minute videos of
this underwater ROV finding stuff and
like this cute wholesome nerdy
commentary from the very excited marine
biologist but it's like really cool and
super fascinating stuff and it's like a
really cute little squid if for two
minutes and you just get to see what the
little squid is up to and like react as
these people are reacting it's so cute
so cute yeah if you have trouble
sleeping or just if you just want a
little two-minute brain break Evie
Nautilus Channel we will have a link ooh
yes that's a lot of links in the
description we're gonna have to like
keep track of all that
whoever's of us is editing this we'll
just write things alright well um I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode it's kind
of like a frolic through the obsession
of youtubes that we have I mean you know
we live the YouTube all the time so this
is incredibly fascinating for us but
maybe we'll return to a more typical
type topic for next time
but anyway so yeah by the way if you do
have a topic suggestion go to
youtube.com slash evident Kaelin podcast
and leave us a suggestion on the
community tab
and while you are on your computer
looking up evident Catelyn podcast stuff
you might as well pop over to iTunes
leave as a five star we appreciate that
we've been we've been doing pretty
steady Caitlyn we even like in the top
between two hundred and fifty of the
iTunes chart for our category so leaving
us a review gets us there keeps us like
talking with these podcasts because
episode iTunes algorithm Peace Corps
revealed just kidding
[Music]